[Music]
[Applause]
everybody to
uh cms colloquium and um
as most of you probably know but uh
bears repeating for those uh guest
attendees
um that the way that we run the the
colloquium is that
um we have our graduate students and
some other members of the mit community
on screen with our guest and
after the presentation there'll be a q a
in which
folks on screen can directly ask
questions and those
who are attendees off screen can
ask questions versus via the q a
bar so um that is very much
encouraged so um uh tonight
i am going to hand over to my colleague
justin reich
to introduce our guest joshua littleberg
tobias great thanks so much for vec and
thanks everybody
for being here um so
we make media as a society for many
purposes we make media to entertain
we make media to persuade we make media
to inform
and one of the things we do is make
media to educate to help people build
new capacities that they didn't have
before
and there are lots of disciplines that
can contribute
um to the study of media that
educates and the learning sciences are
kind of a bundle of those differences
connected to
psychology and cognitive science that
are interested in
um particularly in sort of
technology-inflected ways like how do we
create
media that most effectively build new
capacity
um and so josh and i work in a lab the
teaching systems lab
which is really interested in these
questions of how do we help people
learn better josh has
specialties in measurement and
evaluation
there are lots of different ways to
improve media for
education and one of those ways to
improve media for education is to figure
out whether or not the things you're
doing are working
are if you if you say that you want to
create media
that helps teachers do a better job with
anti-racist teaching what does that even
mean
how would you figure out whether or not
your media is doing the things that you
wanted to do but and you could ask the
same question of
if you make media you know that helps
kids uh
you know learn to divide fractions or
adults to be able to conjugate spanish
verbs how do you know whether or not
what you're doing is really working
how do you know whether or not it's
working better than something else so
that's the that's the expertise that
josh
brings to our interdisciplinary lab
and we've been doing some really cool
work together over the last few months
um to figure out how we can help support
teachers
doing a better job with equity teaching
practices and josh has come up with some
really innovative ways
to help us figure out uh how we're doing
using a combination of quantitative
and qualitative and computational
approaches so i'm really excited to
turn it over to josh to let you all
learn more um about the work that he's
doing with barbeds and many other folks
in the lab
oh i wanted to say one other thing which
is that josh uh has some job
talks coming up for some faculty
positions he's applying for
and this is a bit of a practice for one
of them and
it's actually quite an interdisciplinary
audience at this other talk that he's
giving so you all should feel very free
um to be very candid in your criticism
of josh's uh
talk both on the substance um and on the
delivery if there's stuff that doesn't
make sense or you think doesn't land
well
um you'd be very generous of you to let
him know so he can improve
on those things before the before the
live event coming up
so over to you josh
thanks justin i appreciate the
introduction um
i just wanted to say before i jump into
it that
this is work that um i i've been really
honored to be involved with and i've
worked with a lot of really great uh
people at the mit systems lab um
including
um uh elizabeth gorman who was a
graduate student in cms um uh last year
uh margas who i've worked with for a
number of years
um chris buttimer who's a postdoc and
many many other people who've
contributed to this
research and and so a lot of what i'm
doing some of it a lot of it
um i couldn't have done it without the
help and support
and working with other people um so i'm
going to
share my screen um and
we will get started um so
my talk today is on measuring uh equity
promoting behaviors
in digital teaching simulations and i'm
going to talk a little bit how i used
topic modeling which is a form of
natural language processing
understand what's happening in the
simulations but before i kind of dive
into the specifics that i did i need to
give you
a little bit of background about um
teaching and education to give you kind
of like the 3 000 foot view
to sort of understand kind of what we
did and why
um so just to kind of go over how the
talk would be structured
i'll start with some background about
um the topic and sort of why we looked
at the things that we did uh let's
talk about uh what are digital equity
teaching simulations there's a lot of we
a lot of words there to unpack
then i'll talk about the specific
analysis that i did
using something called structural topic
modeling and i'll explain a little bit
about how
the kind of the inside the hood how that
actually works in practice
um and then i'll present some results
from a
an analysis that i've done worked on
over the last couple months looking at a
course that we
um administered last spring and finally
i'll present some
some future directions about where i see
this research
going over time um so
to start just some uh background
so many of you have heard of the term
the
achievement gap um so this is a term
that's very commonly used
in education policy circles and it
refers to
the difference in achievement
between white and asian students and
black and hispanic and native american
students
and so this is something that
policymakers have been talking about you
know for a long time particularly since
the 1980s and there have been all kinds
of education reform efforts to
close the achievement gap um i know some
of you may have heard of no child left
behind which was under
uh president bush then there was race to
the top with obama
and the 2010s and then there was the
everyday student succeeds acts in 2014
so we've had all these iterations of a
forum
but the thing is there hasn't been a
change so if you look at this
graph that i'm presenting you see that
the achievement gap has pretty much
remained constant
over time since the early 90s so with
all the education reform doing
um there hasn't actually been change in
the achievement um
and particularly in the last few years
there's been
um a lot of criticism of even the term
the achievement gap
there was a research that came out uh
last
summer they actually showed that if you
you kind of frame
um you show people videos about
negative stereotypes about uh
african-american students
and there is a lot of criticism
about framing the achievement gaps uh
framing this thing in terms of a gap
um and and
the reason for this is that by talking
about the gap many people attribute that
to the actual character versus of the
students themselves and not to
the opportunities the students have
experiences students have in school
and so by by focusing on sort of
outcomes
you're ignoring all the inputs and all
the experiences that students are having
that
lead to these uh differences in academic
achievement
um and so in our work uh we
we often um draw on the work of
a scholar called uh named richard milner
who talks about this idea of the
opportunity gap
um so in his work he says that we really
need to focus
um not just on um
like achievement outcomes which are
important we don't want to ignore
differences in outcome
but it's also really important to
understand the reasons for those
differences
and his work in his work he talks about
all the ways that schools
systematically um discriminate against
particularly black and latinx students
and all students of color in the way
that schools are structured
who do students have teachers who look
like them what are the dominant cultures
within schools
how do schools rules and policies how do
they affect students
and there are many many other ways
including curriculum that is not
culturally
responsive um and
standardized testing that doesn't
capture all of students abilities
so these are all factors in this talk
i'm going to talk
i'm going to focus on one specific
aspect of this which is this idea of
discretionary spaces
in teaching um and this idea comes from
the work of
deborah ball which basically said that
in teaching teachers have a lot of
things that they can't control you know
often they can't control when school
happens they can't control
um you know what their classroom
necessary looks like what type of
building they're in
but anyone who's been a teacher knows
that there are a lot of decisions that
teachers have to make every day and that
these decisions
can have a big impact on students
experiences
and in her research he talks about kind
of really examining these discretionary
spaces and understanding
what are the forces that affect uh what
teachers decide to do
um and increasingly thinking about how
do these discretionary spaces
either perpetuate or disroute uh racism
and racist structures
um so for example if you
a teacher sees a student who has their
phone out they have a number of
different choices of what to do they can
just ignore it and keep on teaching they
can you know go over to students say hey
you're not supposed to your phone out
they can confiscate their phone
they can send the student out to the
principal and all the decisions have
um have implications further down the
line we know
from research that discipline in school
is connected to the
school to prison pipeline so even though
you think of this as a sort of
individual
like decision all of these things
accumulate and add up over time
um so i'm gonna kind of transition now
talking about our digital equity
teaching
simulations so in these simulations
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to capture practice in these
discretionary spaces
and i wanted to give you some examples
of what this um
looks like in practice so this is from
one of our simulations called
jeremy sturgeon and to give you
a little background on jeremy's journal
um
in the simulation you play the role of a
teacher
who is um has a student named jeremy and
jeremy is
at uh very actively engaged in class and
other times disengaged
he's generally very friendly and social
but sometimes struggles to kind of focus
on the actual assignment that he's
supposed to be doing
um and one day he misses class
um and you for in you don't get any
reason why he missed class and the next
day
he comes to class and he presents this
note from his
his mom um and
and he says i'm sorry i was out
yesterday i wasn't feeling great and had
to go home
um what do you want me to do for for
makeup work
and he presents this this note from his
mom
and the thing is that the school policy
you know is that you have to have a note
from a doctor
so in this moment what do you do um
response one is say we missed you at
class yesterday
hope you're feeling better or response
two
remember that the school policy is that
you need a signed doctor's note in order
to be excused from class
um and i was wondering if um i wanted to
try something
we'll see how it works i'm going to send
out a poll i only want you to answer the
first
question but i want you to say um which
of these uh two responses would you
choose one
we missed you at class yesterday or two
remember the school's policies that you
need to sign doctors note in order to be
excused from class
so you just need to answer the first
question
okay everyone see the poll all right i
see
okay uh if you can't vote you just put
um either one or two in the chat for for
which one
you would do
okay okay um
seeing um a lot of a lot of ones
so i think we have an agreement um many
people
yeah um i think everyone's panels okay
uh so it's good to know that that that
technology is not
particularly reliable um so
i'm seeing seeing a lot of ones so these
are actual responses that people gave
uh in the simulation when we did this
the course
um so these actually represent two
different ways um that that people
can respond to the situation um and what
we're trying to do
uh with these scenarios is capture these
individual moments of teaching and
provide people with
options like what do i do what would i
do in this moment
and once you do that give them time to
reflect on why am i making the choices
that i'm making are these choices
actually are they perpetuating um
racism or are they disrupting it
um and so why why simulations
um so simulations have a number of
affordances that make them particularly
useful for talking about things
about teaching um one of them
is actually some people might see it as
a limitation
which is that in a simulation you are
representing
some parts of reality but not all of it
so simulation
by definition is not capturing
everything about a real-life teaching
situation
um but in some ways it actually works to
our advantage with teaching because
teaching
is extremely complex activity anyone
who's ever
sit in front of a class of students
knows that there's a lot going on
at any particular moment and so what
we're doing in our simulations is
we're breaking it down into simpler
parts in order to focus people's
attention
on particular things and so it allows
you to really focus
on discrete aspects of moves and
teaching
rather than having to try to kind of
comprehend a large
situation where lots of things are
happening at the same time
another thing that is particularly good
about simulations
is that it allows you to practice skills
within a kind of
simplified lower stake setting and this
is particularly good
for novices who might not be um
ready to take on sort of a more
complicated uh situation and might
benefit from doing things
in a lower stakes simplified environment
but even
for more experienced teachers it's often
helpful to take a step back
and kind of be reflective and think
about okay um now that i'm out of my
classroom i'm a matter of fact
what i actually do in this situation and
they think about it and talk about it
and the final thing that is helpful with
simulations
is that it allows you to kind of provide
opportunities for targeted reflection
and feedback and they use the term
targeted hearing intentionally
um because one of the things we know
about learning new skills
is that it doesn't necessarily help to
kind of do the same thing
over and over and over again what what
allows you to improve is to say do you
have deliberate practice focusing on a
specific
skill set and getting feedback on that
skill set so what we're trying to do in
our simulations is really be
very intentional focus on specific
things and using those
for opportunities for reflection and
feedback in order to facilitate
learning um so i've kind of set up
like what like some of the background
about influencing your work i talked
about why simulations
now i wanted to talk a little bit about
actual texas simulations we built
um so the teaching system lab has
developed a platform called teacher
moments i know
many of you are familiar with teacher
moments either through
the teaching systems lab or edtech
design studio
or just sort of being around the cms
department um
but what's really cool about teacher
moments is that it's a platform for
authoring simulation so anyone
can go and build their own simulations
in teacher moments
it's free openly licensed people can use
it however they want
and we've had more than 300 scenarios
authored within teacher moments and have
had
more than 6 000 users and more and more
people are using it
every day so i definitely encourage you
um if you're interested to check out
future moments and kind of
see sort of some of the features of that
i wanted to give you
a flavor of what a scenario what a
teacher moment scenario actually is like
um many times we talk about these
simulations people assume oh you're
doing something in
vr or you're doing something um that's
sort of you know
different from what it actually is and
so i think it's helpful
uh to actually kind of see what a
simulation looks like so i'm going to
play
about a three minute clip um one
of um
and i'm going to share computer sound so
you can hear it so this is a clip from
one of our simulations called roster
justice
and the background to this is in this
simulation you play a teacher
who a few weeks before school you get
your your class roster
um and you notice that the computer
science
class that you're supposed that
you're supposed to teach the rosters are
in balance
so even though your school is um
50 african-american and latinx
the actual composition in the class is
mostly white and asian
and male students and so you go to the
principal mr hall who is played by
uh justin in this scenario
you're gonna have a conversation with
him about your
the class rosters
thanks for coming in um i wanted to talk
with you about some of the scheduling
changes and i also heard that you wanted
to
talk to me um we've got someone else
coming in a few minutes
uh so why don't we cut to the chase why
don't you lay it all out for me
thank you mr hall for a meeting with me
i know that you have a busy schedule
before we talk about the scheduling
changes i just wanted to share my
concerns
i looked over the rosters for computer
science
and i noticed that the computer science
class doesn't reflect our student
population
and has way more white students
and male students than we have in the
rest of the school
and i'm concerned that it means that our
students of color and our female
students are missing out on some
opportunities
to take computer science so can we talk
a little bit about how we might be able
to change the schedule so more students
can take
computer science
[Music]
well first i'd like to say thank you for
bringing the issue to my attention
i get your concerns really i do um
unfortunately there's not a lot that we
can do
school is starting just three weeks from
now what are some quick fixes that you
or i
or someone else could do right now this
year
i don't think that there are any quick
fixes i think we need to take a broader
look at how we do scheduling
because of the way we schedule things we
ended up systematically excluding a
group of students from computer science
um and these are students who
historically haven't had opportunities
to take computer science classes so i
think it's a serious problem that we
need to address
i want to be super clear we cannot
change the schedules
at this point um sometimes imbalances
will happen when you only offer
one section of a course like we're doing
this year with intro to cs
we're offering intro to cs during period
five i mean super complicated we're
offering
intro to cs and period five we're
offering algebra in period five
and period one so anyone who has intro
to cs for period five
just is gonna have to take algebra in
period one um
what if i got you a teaching assistant
to help with the class
i don't think it's super complicated
there are a few weeks left before school
starts we change kids schedules all the
time
and i don't think a teaching assistant
solves the underlying problem
why can't we look into changing when the
math courses are scheduled so that all
of our kids can have a chance to take
computer science
um thanks for coming in so
i hope you guys enjoyed uh that scenario
um and appreciated having justin play
the uh
angry uh principal i know that um
one of the things i find even though
i've done the scenario many many
times every time i do it i still feel
that jolt of like oh i'm talking to the
principal
um like what's he gonna think of me and
like how can i make this argument i
think that that
kind of shows the affordances of these
types of simulations that even though
i'm just talking to a video
i know that the video isn't going to
actually respond
in the moment it's not a real person i
still feel that that emotion
as i'm going through scenario a lot of
our our simulations are like this that
even though they're not necessarily
capturing all the authentic
what it would be like in the moment
there's something about it
that makes it feel very authentic and we
found when we've
done this with now thousands of people
people often say
yes it does feel authentic it feels like
something that would actually happen
in real life and that's really a
testament to
all the people who work to design these
scenarios to be really
impactful so last spring
we launched the course course called
becoming a more equitable educator
and we took these um simulations and we
put them
within within the course um so the way
that the course was structured
um is that within each unit
um you would sort of be introduced to a
topic and then you would do a simulation
about that topic and then after you did
the simulation
um you would watch a video of other
teachers you actually went to different
schools around the country
did the simulations the teacher and
filmed the debrief of a debrief with
them
doing the simulations that included
interviews with individual people
talking about the decisions that they
made
so even though um it was an online
course it was obviously last march
like right when covid was starting um so
many people were sort of turning
um to online learning that time so even
though it's online you're able to see
kind of what other people are thinking
and doing um
in that moment and the course itself was
structured
around this idea of educator mindsets
and we framed it around four
pairs of mindsets and the idea is that
these are things
mindsets that are out of balance in um
us schools so just to give an example uh
one of the mindsets that we looked at is
equity versus equality
so equity is that sort of everyone
gets the thing that they need and if
some people need more things they should
get those things and we should focus on
individual need not on giving everyone
the same thing
while equality means that everyone gets
the exact
same thing um and we shouldn't give
people special treatment
now what we argue is that it's not that
equity is good and equality is bad um
but the problem is that these mindsets
are currently out of balance that we
have too much equality
and not enough equity in schools and
what we want to do is we want to shift
people's focus to thinking about as they
make these decisions
how can i act with more of an equity
mindset um
and so in all of our the units in the
course each of them was framed around
these pairs of mindsets and there was a
simulation that was attached
to each of them so this is all kind of a
setup for the research
that um we ended up doing so
um in the in the course there were
963 people who had did at least one
uh simulation um and there were four
simulations in the course
each of them that was embedded within
one of the units
um someone says it's difficult to read
the presentation can everyone see
my slides do i need to um make it bigger
i think if you can just if you don't
mind sharing the link
sure yeah i'm happy to do that um
yeah i'm happy to do that uh let me
there i will put it in
[Music]
thank you for that feedback um
okay i'm putting the link in the chat so
people can
um okay thank you uh
i will go back to the presentation
um so as i was saying we we had four of
these simulations embedded within the
course
each within one of the units um so
we had a lot a lot a lot of text data
probably more text data than any person
could
look at qualitatively so i was
interested in
how can we use natural language
processing tools to automate
some of this analysis to understand what
are people
doing in these simulations um and so
um i looked into different ways of using
natural language processing
um there has been a lot of research
about that has
used natural language processing within
um large-scale data sets
um just to give a few examples um
they've used it to do uh automatic
scoring
of cognitive tasks or sort of machine
swearing of assessments
um people have used it to predict
people's effective states so
there's one study that looked at what
are students
um feelings about math and they looked
at people's
responses within a online math
curriculum
and correlated that with student um
self-efficacy
uh for for for math and then
a study that justin actually worked on
was looking
at responses in discussion forums and
trying to see
um and this was of course um that was a
political course so do conservatives and
liberals
how do they engage with each other
within discussion forums
so there's a lot of different ways that
you can use um
natural language processing to make
sense of
large data sets and i was particularly
interested in can we use these tools um
with our simulation data can they
provide us some information about what
are people's experiences
within these simulations and the
particular
method i used was something called
structural topic modeling
so a topic model is a
model that detects underlying patterns
within large data sets by identifying
latent topics within
within a text uh
data set um and what's nice about topic
modeling is it does not require any a
priority assumptions about the structure
of the data so you don't have to have
labeled data in order to use topic
modeling it draws the topics from
uh the the data itself so this was
particularly good because we didn't have
any labeled data so it was a
particularly good for this
type of data set and we're also
interested in exploring like what are
people doing
within within the simulations um we used
a uh what's called a mixture model so
this is how the
the topic model works it basically
estimates a probability
of a topic appearing within a text and a
word appearing within a topic and i'll
kind of give you a little illustration
of how that process actually works
and the particular form of topic
modeling that i use
is allows you to include covariates that
allow you to see associations between
a topic appearing and some
characteristic about
a person um and i'll kind of kind of
dive into that a little bit later and
show you
how that work within our analysis um
so this is kind of the the pipeline for
how
uh structural topic modeling uh works so
kind of the input is um is your text
data and in our case it was sort of a
big
excel file with each row was a different
response
within the simulation so mostly
simulations you saw sort of three of the
ones from roster justice
all the simulations were basically kind
of prompts and then people wrote in
wrote in or said their answers and we
automatically transcribe those answers
so you kind of have this big uh you know
basically excel file of data
so you take that data and the first
thing you do is you have to process that
data
and this is important because within
those
pieces of text there's a lot of words
that are not that informative
so things uh conjugations like and
or prepositions uh pronouns like
all those don't really provide you a lot
of information about what's happening
within the text
so the sort of general acceptance rule
is to kind of pull those out
of of of the of the of
the text that you're looking at another
thing we did was stemming which is to
say
like getting rid of all of the um
conjugations so like um you know
for example explore could be explorers
exploring
explored exploration we took all it took
all those and kind of made them one
single word so that way it focuses on
the content and not on the particular
way that it's used within a sentence
another thing that we did is we
separated it out
by line so i was interested in topics
appearing within individual responses
and i thought that there might be
multiple topics and so a way to kind of
pinpoint when a topic is occurring um is
by
uh separating that into individual lines
and this kind of ended up giving us
you know even more rows of data to look
at and finally
under the recommendation um from
the authors of the of the structural
topic model i removed infrequent words
so words that didn't appear that
frequently within each document
took them out we ended up still with you
know over a thousand
different words within each simulation
and kind of
what you end up with is this document
term matrix so it's basically like think
of like a big
um excel file and each column
is a word and each row
is a different piece of text or what's
called
in the uh in the natural language
processing world
documents so basically if a word appears
in the document
it's quoted as one and if it's if if it
doesn't it's quoted as a zero and this
is for every single document in in the
text
and what the structural topic modeling
does is it takes that really new matrix
and it kind of looks for correlations
between
words within documents and uh documents
that are have the same word and it kind
of spits
out um a set of topics that
uh have certain words that are
associated with them and
and documents that have certain topics
that are associated with them
the the challenge is that you have to
specify in advance
how many topics you want so the topic
model will spit out 60 topics that will
spit out five topics you have to figure
out
kind of using some metrics how many
topics do you actually
want the model to produce and there's a
number of different ways that you can do
that to kind of figure out
what is the right number of topics to
extract
the larger issue is that the topics
don't come pre-labeled so it's not like
it spits it out it says this topic
is about you know baseball like you have
to to assign those things yourself
now sometimes it's more obvious and
sometimes it's less obvious
those of you if you're familiar with um
factor analysis or cluster analysis
the same issue where the the model will
kind of
group your data but then you have to as
the researcher have to figure out what
does this data actually mean
um so i'm going to walk you through
example of how we kind of came up with
labels and this was sort of
trying to show you how the topic model
works um
so these were two topics um
that appeared in um uh
the model that i ran for jeremy's
journal um
so one of them is topic seven um
and in this graph the purple dot is
the probability of it appearing within
topic
um topic uh
seven and the the it was actually
reversed
um but the the green dot is the
probability of it appearing in topic ten
um and so i was interested and this
graph kind of illustrates both the
probability of a word appearing in topic
seven
and then the probability of it appearing
in the other topic
you can see that certain words are more
likely to appear within one topic
and less likely to appear in the other
within another topic
so for topic seven the words today
yesterday better feel are very likely to
occur within that topic
well for topic 10 dr axe's note mom
those ones are more likely to appear um
so this is kind of giving us some sense
of like what is actually going on in
that topic
um so now i'm going to give you a phrase
you're going to have to
i want you in the chat to say which
topic do you think that this piece of
text
come from is it from um topic
7 or topic 10 so just to give you a
reminder this is the
this is the words for topic 7 and these
are the words for topic 10. so
i want look at this um thing and just
sort of this do you think it's a topic
seven or a topic tag
i'm gonna go back to the uh
okay i see a lot of sevens um
and you were right the model agreed with
you
and said there was a 75 percent
probability of this this
of this piece of text containing topic
7.
um now let's try this one
remember the school's policies that you
need to sign doctor's note in order to
be exclusive class so is this topic 7 or
topic 10
just write in the chat
seeing a lot of tens and again
you guys are right uh the model is
training you exactly
uh uh it was a 60 model said there was
65 percent probability of topic 10
appearance
um i should say not all of the topics
were this clearly delineated between two
sometimes it's a little more ambiguous
what exactly the model is detecting um
but we
what we did is something kind of similar
to this process where we look
at what documents
the model said was likely to that topic
was likely to appear in
and the words that were highly
associated with that topic and kind of
through that process me and some other
graduates
research decisions graduate students we
uh came up with topics so
for topic seven we labeled that glad
jeremy is feeling better
and for top of ten uh we labeled it
doctor's note
uh and school policy and we did this for
all the topics that were distracted in
all of this
all of the simulations um
um so once we extracted the topics
what we were interested in was are these
topics associated with anything
are they associated with participants
attitudes toward equity and remember i
said earlier that the structural topic
model allowed you to include
predictors so in this case we wanted to
know
was there a relationship between
what participants said on surveys in
terms of their attitudes toward equity
and we had
surveys for each of the mindsets in in
the course so there was a survey for
equity inequality there's a certain
agreement for deficit and asset
um and we wanted to see is there
association between how i responded to a
survey
and what topics i noticed uh within the
simulations
um and what was really exciting for us
was that there was a pretty strong
connection
that certain topics um you were more
likely to
uh notice if you had reported on a
survey more of an equality mindset
uh and there were certain topics that
you were more likely to notice in more
equity mindset
so what's interesting is that the uh
doctors know people who mentioned the
doctors know were much more likely to
have an equality mindset
well people who asked jeremy how they
were feeling were much more likely to
mention service they had equity mindset
we found this in all of the simulations
that we did that there was association
between what topics you noticed
and um your your your mindsets on
surveys
um so this was exciting for us to think
about like our simulations
are these simulations actually measuring
something real about what people think
and believe having to do with equity
um but that's sort of good for like a
measurement piece but
um people justin and people
of course were also interested in did
these courses actually work
like did people actually change in their
mindsets over time
um so i wanted to look at is there a way
that we could use these simulations to
understand are people actually changing
in their uh mindsets over time
um the problem is that we had four
different simulations so you can't
compare the topics
from one simulation to the next because
they were totally different simulations
of totally different subjects
so the topics are not necessarily
comparable but what we could do um
is we could compare you
to a set group of people um so what we
did is for each
for each simulation i calculated the
maximum probability that any topic would
appear in your responses
so you kind of end up with a with a a
table like this so for each topic
each row is an individual user and
there's a probability
that that topic would appear in any of
the user's responses for that simulation
um and so this is not real data but
you can this is sort of what it looks
like some people were more likely to
mention one topic some people more
likely to mention other topics
um and then i was interested okay so we
have all that data
um let's compare them to the people who
started the course
with the highest equity beliefs on the
survey so i took the
top quartile the top 25 percent of
people on
on their pre-survey in terms of their um
their uh educator mindset beliefs and
were they more shifted toward
equity or equality or asset versus
deficit
so i wanted to see like do other people
in the course do they become
more similar in the topics that they're
mentioning in the simulations
to those group of high equity users
and so i'm going to show you example
from our first simulation
um i want to go back and explain
something so how do you
see how similar people's topics are to
each other
um well use this console called
euclidean distance um
so those of you who remember uh
[Music]
trigonometry you know b squared
and you know the pythagorean theorem so
this is basically like
what is the distance between one point
and any other point
and i basically took each person's um
topics and looked at okay how similar is
my responses to
this other person's responses and the
closer my responses were
on to their responses the more similar
um
i would say that my responses are and so
you can see in this example like
if these are like the top reference
group this person's responses
is closer to uh this person's responses
so this is just
not what the data really looks like it's
actually not
two dimensions it's many many many
dimensions but this is sort of a basic
idea what we're talking about we're
talking about distance
um so in jeremy's journal
the people in the fourth the first
quartile so with the lowest equity
beliefs
were the furthest away from that
reference group so their responses were
the least
like that top 25 um reference group
and these percentages here it represents
sort of on average for any topic how far
percentage-wise my response was so it's
not a huge number it's not like
you know 30 60
versus 30 but on average there's about a
four percent difference in any topic
between someone
in the highest group and then someone
who started
uh in the lowest category um
and so as interested as this is the
first simulation how did people change
over the four simulations in the course
um and so it was really exciting for us
is that
um in the first simulation um you see
that
one these other people in the first
second and third quarter
quartile they're all kind of further
away from
the people in the four quartile and as
they progress through the course
they all get closer both to each other
and to the fourth quartile
so i think what this is showing is that
people are becoming more
similar over successive simulations and
in this data i'm only looking at people
who did all four simulations in the
course so it's not that
you know people are dropping off and the
last equitable people are leaving
basically we're actually seeing people
are changing to become more similar to
people in that fourth quartile
over the course of the course um so just
to summarize
uh natural language processing tools
such as structural topic modeling
can help with these large uh simulation
data sets to understand what's happening
in these simulations
and to identify topics that are emerging
and
what was really exciting for us was our
we would kind of bring these results to
our designers and they would say yeah i
actually included that
that thing in that simulation on purpose
i want to see how people respond
so it's interesting that the that the
machine learning model was actually able
to pick up on some of those
nuances um the second thing is that what
you notice when people
notice and mention the simulation was
associated with their beliefs and
attitudes
so the suggestion that simulation is
capturing differences between people
and how they respond to different types
of situations
and finally that interesting way of
evaluating
learning is that we can see by comparing
simulations over time you can see
how people change in terms of their
beliefs and did they become
and becoming more similar converging
with
one another as the course progressed um
i know we're we're running a short time
i just wanted to briefly uh talk about
two
future directions uh one is that
uh we're going we put in a grant to do a
study where we're
actually going to be doing this with
teachers
in grades three through eight in uh five
different
districts across the country so although
our moocs have a lot of educators
it's usually just people who kind of
randomly come into the course or hear
about it
so in this way we're actually going to
go out and recruit people and we're
going to be able to link it to
data about their students so we're
interested to know
does your response in a simulation is
that actually predictive
of student outcomes and because right
now we don't really know
whether these these behaviors are
actually predictive of anything outside
the simulation
so we're hoping with this study to
actually understand a little bit more
about how is behavior in the stimulation
connected to behavior
outside the simulation ultimately how
does this affect students experiences
um and then this other thing i'm really
excited about is this idea of being able
to give
automated formative assessment and
feedback within the simulation
so i'm going to play a short clip of
what
uh ross and josh roster justice could
look like in the future
um so this is like from the last prompt
that you heard
so anyone who has intro to cs for period
five just is gonna have to take algebra
in period one um what if i got you a
teaching assistant to help with the
class
um so now i'm writing uh that does sound
super complicated
uh yes a teaching assistant would
be great so i'm submitting it and
dancing pops up and says remember that
your main concern is the imbalance in
classes
does your teaching assistant solve that
problem um
so this is actually feedback that
someone to facilitate every given person
so we're
we're hoping to use um uh
machine learning models to actually be
able to detect like when are people
saying
yeah teaching a system would be great to
be able to give them that automated
feedback
um something marvis actually has been
doing a lot of work on
um over the past few weeks so i'm hoping
that this is something that we could
actually implement
uh in the near future um so
so um thanks again for for listening to
my talk i'm
i'm glad i was able to come and talk to
you and i'm really excited to hear your
questions and to hear kind of
what what you think about all this
all right i'm going to open it up to
questions questions
[Music]
um i have one myself
um i i guess i wanted to um
get a sense of i wasn't quite
um clear on uh
when you showed the simulation the first
time yeah
um how how that works in terms of how
it's been
how the simulation has been built to
respond to
verbal responses um is it
uh and and what responses
like pre-recorded responses from the
principle
um you know what is the spectrum of
responses
from the principle that that are going
to be
potentially chosen
you know algorithmically to respond to
various responses or various inputs from
the
the person who's going through the
simulation
yeah that's a really great question uh
question uh the short answer is that it
does it now like there's no algorithm no
matter what you say
justin will give the same response um in
that simulation
um i think there's actually two things
one is that
we had it when we built this we hadn't
sort of started to develop
the technology to be able to respond um
in real time
to have more responsive uh video
um but the other thing is that often if
you're having an argument with someone
like what you say does like you're
actually not talking
to each other you're actually like
having a conversation where like you say
something the other person just sort of
ignores what you're saying so we've
actually found with the
the argument types of simulations
that it actually works pretty well to
have somebody have a conversation with
someone who
totally ignores what they are saying um
and
the the person who designed this also
was really knowledgeable about schools
and how these conversations worked
and so when she was designing it i think
she she really thought about like the
types of things that are principles
would say in that moment
yeah i was actually going to say that
that
the lack of varied responses from the
principal is probably
closer to reality than if you tried to
create multiple responses
i have other questions but i want to
make open the floor to everyone
um well i have my next question which is
um
just related to the um
uh the the future directions that you
just spoke about
um and you were talking about um
the potential um
uh testing in the field
um where i just remember the number
252 i don't know i don't remember if
that's 252
uh teachers or or schools
um teachers teachers right
okay and so i guess the question that i
have there is
um if they are self-selecting um
to take part in the simulations is it
um you know how are you correcting for
the possibility that
those teachers who were open to um
to going through these similar
simulations that are
geared towards
you know shaping
or geared towards guiding people towards
a a more
equity based mind um mindset
um that would that be a self-selecting
set of teachers who
would already be sort of um
a closer to that mindset or be more
willing and open to have their mindset
changed through a process like this if
that makes sense
yeah so i actually think what you're
pointing out is a good observation about
the the course the online course that we
did
um because you know we the course is
is sort of open and free and anyone can
take it but
the types of people who take it are the
types of people who already care about
equity issue equity issues so one of the
challenges kind of right up front is
that there wasn't a lot there wasn't as
much variation
in the types of responses um as we would
have liked so like even those
i would say like you know i said the the
low equity
the first quartile but that first
worldwide probably most schools would
actually be probably like
some of the more equitable educators
within that school um the people who are
probably
like the most in need of the course are
probably the least likely
to be taking it um i think and
one of the things that we want to do
with that study that i was proposing
is do more active recruitment of
teachers
so we're going to be working with
districts to
sort of identify schools to participate
in study will actually be
like recruiting teachers and paying them
money to participate
in in this course um and so i think what
we're hoping is that we'll get
a broader and more diverse group of
teachers than the types of teachers that
we got in
in took the mood and hopefully we'll be
able to reach teachers who wouldn't
necessarily
like be pursuing an online course about
equity
on their own
uh roya and then tomas was that
and no okay i was curious and sorry i'm
outside so if you can't hear me that's
why
um i know that something we've thought
about a lot
on the project that i work on the lab is
sort of
how we transition a shift in mindset to
a shift
in practice and i would love to hear
kind of your
your thoughts on that in terms of this
work and where you see that going
with kind of the implementation of
features
yeah i mean i think it's a it's a
measurement challenge especially in a
mooc because
um you know we get we don't know in
advance
who who was going to take our course and
they kind of show up and
you know it's not like we can um like
be like okay we're going to go to your
class on this day we actually
were planning at one point to send uh
chris butterworth or the postdoc who
works on this project
we had a whole plan last march that he
was going to like find schools and
contact them and travel all around the
country to do observations
um but then obviously covet happened so
that's not that that kind of was not no
longer a possibility
um but i think that it would be um
like i'm really excited about the work
that you're talking about in spiderman i
think it'll be really
interesting to actually see kind of what
what what are teacher like if someone
does something in simulation
is that related at all to to to to their
actual practice um and
is there is there a correlation there um
i suspect that that there is based on
like what we've seen in terms of
like survey responses but it'd be
interesting to kind of actually connect
that to actual
practice
how much um
yeah my question was really similar to
reyes
but i think maybe i can frame it in a
different way
um so um yeah first of all thank you for
the representation look extremely
interesting and
i'm really excited to to what can be
done with this methodology
um so um this would assume from the
assumption
that there is a goal to increase an
equity mindset right
and i was wondering um i mean this is
something that i
can probably get behind out and behind
off but i wonder if
um if there are other possibilities to
do this
like with other values other normative
values that
that maybe are sourced from teachers and
maybe
like not from academic labs but to see
what what the
of it's here so i have to say about that
and i was also wondering
if um
um yeah so i think this is pretty much
what you just answered to
roya but i guess the what well
the the conclusion from from from this
method is that you can tell people
that certain uh certain um yeah actions
are associated with a certain mindset
but i wonder what's like the extra step
right like um and i i guess that's what
you
address in the mooc so i was wondering
if you could
discuss one of the concepts of that word
yeah um
let me know if i understand your
question right um are you asking like
you know what is like okay we can
measure these things but how is it
actually gonna
change people's practice is that kind of
similar to that so it's two different
questions the first one
is whether you could like chime in other
normative values instead of equity if
you can think like you know
if they want to make more solidarity
teachers like what does that mean
and the second question would be to if
you could talk about the mooc experience
like how can you turn this
insights and get through this data into
just specific practices
yeah um so i think the first thing is
that we we've done
so equity is sort of one area that we've
worked on but we've done it in
a number of other areas including um
roya has has done a lot of work on math
um instruction uh which is less
it's less a question of um and wrote you
could disagree with anything that's
wrong
it's more of a sort of teaching sort of
skill sets than
a kind of normative value although there
probably are ignorant values that are
baked
into those particular skills that we're
trying to teach uh we also
marcus and i worked on a course called
civic online reasoning
which was about preparing teachers to
teach students how to identify
misinformation
online so it's based on a method
developed by
a group at stanford called basically to
call lateral reading where you you if
you see something online
instead of like spending a long time
reading through and trying to determine
is this real is this not real
um which is sort of the traditional way
that teachers have been taught to how to
teach
information literacy they say that the
best thing to do is actually google it
to
google and see like who is behind the
information um
another important thing in that that
course is that many teachers and
many of you probably experienced this
like i think that wikipedia is bad
like basically that wikipedia is totally
unreliable as a source
um but we know that actually you know
there are some
issues with wikipedia but it can be
really reliable especially
for finding sort of basic information
about something and
wikipedia also cites a lot of the
sources so you can go to those sources
and look up the information
um so that we actually developed uh
practice space as
practice-based simulations to um
to like have people kind of do these
exercises to see how much they've
learned uh about
that particular skill set um and marvis
has
has i hope this is okay i'm fighting
your work but they they've done this
really cool
uh uh classifier that basically detects
like
if response to one of these tasks and
say like okay
did you figure out that this tweet was
from a parody or account or
or not um and we're hoping to use those
to give people
um feedback on learning um
i think ultimately so like answer
to your second question um so we have
some data from our course um and it's
all
self-reported so you know taking
whatever grains of salt you need to that
people over the course
[Music]
were more likely after the course and
particularly four months afterwards to
discuss
um equity issues in their schools and to
participate in networks around equity
so there's some evidence that the course
um after getting the first people more
likely to engage in actions around
equity
um learning and i would really be
interested in learning more
about like what does that actually look
like and is there a relationship between
taking the course and doing these things
that's actually one of the reasons why
we're proposing this
um study uh is to do a
randomized experiment where we assign
randomly assigned teachers to take the
course and we see this actually change
their behavior so i think it's
definitely something that
i'm really interested in as research and
also interested in like
can stuff like a online virtual course
can that actually
affect behavior in the real world
thank you
uh ambar and then there's the question
in the
q a from will
humber thank you yes thank you vivek and
joshua
i i was wondering so when you may
like when you ask us like which option
would
we choose we all chose one right and
like like that relates to equity but i'm
just wondering like even though
like if teachers answer one and they are
more likely
to uh think
about equity also i guess like the
the school rules also affect right
so i was wondering if you have thought
about actually making simulation
to change uh the way the principal
thinks yeah about it rather than the
like the professors because
they could you know like they could
think about liquidity
but you know like the rules are the
rules so i'm yeah
yeah yeah and i think that's a really
great point and something that
you know comes up a lot in the course is
that
you know we intentionally frame the
course around
um these sort of individual moments in
teaching
um and the reason we did that is
probably because those are the easiest
to change so like i as an individual
teacher
i can like make the choice to like
interact with the student differently
or push for something or like bring
something out with my colleagues
it's more difficult to sort of use more
systemic issues
i think our theory of change um is that
like if if people start to notice these
things
in their practice and they start to talk
about other people that kind of builds
up the momentum to
sort of change some of these bigger
things so like
you know an individual person saying
like hey actually
like let's think about how our school's
policy about the doctor don't how does
that affect
you know students who may not have
health insurance or may not be able to
easily get to a doctor made out of
transportation like
how does this policy affecting those
particular students so i feel like
like we start with sort of the
individual and that can kind of lead to
some of the more systemic changes
great there's um will's question and
then emily added on to
to that question so i'm gonna read these
um so others can can hear them but feel
free to
follow along in the in the chat bar um
so
will writes i'm interested in the notion
of discretionary spaces
in classrooms and the types of
situations in which they arise
i'm curious about how you go about
deciding
which specific types of discretionary
spaces
slash scenarios to focus on in the
simulations
that you develop for the courses and
then
emily adds it's also interesting to
think about whether or not teachers
understand them
as discretionary or not in particular
contexts
um and would interact with changes in
their interest
in enforcing school rules which yeah
so yeah um so all these scenarios um
are developed um based on sort of real
things that have
happened in schools all the time um i
know my wife
uh is is an educator and she's always
like me i'm always like okay kind of
kind of use that example that you just
did i think it's perfect one
for our teacher moments and so i think
kind of like the characteristics of a
good
like discretionary space is one where
the this the
answer isn't obvious i think the one i
gave you actually was a little bit more
obvious than like a
really good one would be but like has
some
sort of tension between like do i want
to do this thing or that because if it
was an obvious decision
that everyone would just do that but
there has to be something kind of
countervailing then um that would make
you think well maybe i don't want to do
that um
one of the things at the end of the of
the
jeremy's journal uh simulation is that
he asked because he's missed school and
because of
you know he asked if he can if he can be
excused from taking
a quiz that you give every week and so
he comes up he was like
can i get out of this quiz and whenever
we've done this we've gotten many many
different responses
and there isn't really a right answer
it's not like if you give him the quiz
you're like not equitable and if you
don't give me the quiz you're equitable
or vice versa because there's you know
reasons for wanting to give them the
quiz i think what's important is like
your reasoning behind it
so many people will say like oh i'm
giving him
the quiz because i want to know how he's
doing and then i'll give him feedback
and we'll talk about it i'll understand
more about like what is going on with
him versus someone who's saying oh
i i don't want him to give him the quiz
because like everyone else has to take
the quiz and that's just the rule and
he's got to adjust this is the real
world like no one's going to care about
his situation at home
um so like the decision is not as
important as the reasoning behind it and
that's actually why i
think that the the natural language
processing is so important
uh is because we could just constructed
scenarios it's like multiple choice like
do this or do that
but it doesn't kind of tell you like why
like why did you want to do this and
that's where i think
some of the text analysis stuff really
comes into play it allows us to
understand some of the nuances of why
people pick something and not the other
thing
marquez a great presentation
josh um well i just was wondering if you
could go into a little bit more
about um like the development of the
scenarios like who are
the designers and like how we plan for
research
especially in the context of ies where
we're going to be doing it over
all these districts with all these
different teachers in different contexts
yeah um you're saying like how do you
how would you decide to work for
different types of
audiences um
yeah i mean i think like one of the the
challenges especially in a mooc is that
you're doing it for a global
audience so you're doing it for people
who are
um who are um
like may not be as familiar with certain
things in the u.s context
i think what works well
is like the universal enough experience
that many
like people could identify with it so
even if the specifics are not the same
um
i know this is actually something where
i thought like originally like oh people
aren't going to get this jeremy sternal
scenario because it's so like specific
to like
u.s schools but when i actually listen
to data people a lot of people got it
really understood what was happening
there even if they don't understand it
like the specific details aren't
important and that's that's where i
think that the
like the characters and their art is
really where and i guess this kind of
connects to the media piece like
this is what makes the scenario
meaningful and meaningful as a learning
experience
is if you can kind of connect to what's
actually happening
in the in this situation
i have another question that's that is
more
um i guess geared towards
um you know taking this opportunity
um to talk about
uh methodology since half of our
students are
are taking a media research
methodologies class
with me at the moment so um
i wanted to just ask you about
the research design and and sort of
iterative does
design-based research um
specifically in relation to uh the
natural language processing and how
um how you've built that out
um you know what what are the steps when
you're
um when you're building that what are
the steps that you
go through um in order to fine-tune
um how that works
yeah um so it was a very iterative
process
i would say um it wasn't something where
i was like i know exactly what i want to
do like from the beginning
um i had like we had been doing these
scenarios
for some some time before we did the
course
and so i had some understanding of like
what the universe of possible responses
were to these types of scenarios so i
knew that like there were certain
patterns to like what people
how people would respond and like
there were kind of like you could kind
of like see like oh people
respond like this way or they respond
this way um
but all that data you know was sort of
like a small sample so i didn't actually
know exactly how it would
how it would work when we kind of did it
on larger scale
um the other sort of like decision
that i had to make um i hope this isn't
getting too into the weeds is like
thinking about the goal with using the
natural language processing
so like one approach um could have been
to say like okay i'm gonna like
score each of these responses and like
see if i can build a kind of classifier
to predict like what are people
are people um you know
acting equitably or not equitably but i
kind of wanted to leave it open-ended to
feel
like i'm not going to like pre-determine
what is equitable and what is not
equitable i want to see like based on
the data
like what are people um what are people
noticing and what are the differences
between people and what they notice so
that's kind of the like
framework i used and why i hear i was
sort of leaning toward more
um unsupervised models that would allow
kind of allow the data to sort of like
uh generate
and then once i had it then that was a
kind of like as i was saying like
labeling
um is not always um
is it kind of a difficult process
because you can kind of you have to make
a subjective decision about
what data means and that's where i
actually did a lot of conversations
with the people who designed the
simulations looking at the data
talking um other people getting some
kind of validation by thinking about
like
okay do other people see the same things
that i'm seeing because
it is a it's subjective that you want it
to sort of be like transferable so other
people
could kind of come to a similar
conclusion um i think that's one of the
challenges with this type of analysis is
that there is some
like research or subjectivity and you
don't want to sort of hide that behind
the like
objectivity of like these are the
numbers you want to say like this is the
process
that i use to kind of come to this this
conclusion
um but actually we actually did
i actually had people like um
who weren't involved at all in the
design of the model like i gave them
like
a task where they had to choose which
talks kind of like what we
did in this exercise like i like
selected a piece of text
um and then like gave them a bunch of
different topics and one of them was the
one that the models
said it was most associated with um and
so we actually could predict
like had them say like themselves and
basically doing what the model was
like you know which topic is most
associated with this piece of text and
it actually was
matched the the model that's 65 of the
time
so it wasn't like a perfect connection
and often it was in cases where the
model was kind of iffy about like what
what was actually in the text
so i think it's like one of those cases
where like the more
like cases where it's more clear-cut it
was easier for
for people to kind of correspond with
them with the model
and in cases where it was less clear-cut
there was more ambiguity there
just a a quick follow-up
is um you know you touched on just now
um the um
how a particular response
you know might be i think you were
um using the example of of whether or
not to give
the the student the um the
test and how they're you know one
two teachers who decide to give the the
student that test might have different
reasoning
um one of which is more aligned with
equitable mindset and one is not
um to um
and maybe this is partly you know
already answered but i'm
curious about how that kind of um
qualitative assessment um is
built into the overall
project yeah you know whether um
you know so that you can since like
you're saying you're not
pre-determining um in the model which
which kind of response corresponds to
equitable
mindset and which is not and so that in
the
those those kind of like fine areas or
gray areas
yeah it seems like more qualitative
engagement with the subjects
yeah or with the teachers is sort of
what will give you
the data that you need and so i'm
curious how
you know the the kind of interplay
between um
that kind of qualitative method
um and the kind of modeling that you're
doing yeah
yeah i mean i think i see like justin's
comment about like using
unsupervised approaches to couple of
traditional qualitative
bottom grounded theory types of analysis
and i think that's actually a good
analogy
for like how do we you know
look at this type of data because you
know
in the course it was probably you know
over a hundred thousand rows of data so
you know we could have coded all that
data but i'd probably still be working
on it now
um and what was really interesting was
like
once you see once you kind of can see
what's happening
in the data then you can sort of start
to put on some of your your
your qualitative lens and kind of do
some more
looking at like what does this actually
mean
um i'm sort of my training is
quantitative but also done some mixed
method and qualitative research and
i'm i'm sort of interested in kind of
that
that space of like how can we use like
large data numbers but also kind of
understand
like you know more qualitatively like
what are people thinking
and how is it you know that you can't
actually
it's more difficult to capture with like
a multiple choice like
service item so this is why like i'm
very excited about this type of
methodology going forward
thank you um
other questions
okay um
well we can um we're
almost at at 6 30.
i have one last suggestion this is
justin sorry my house is chaos so i'm
not gonna
it's okay that's okay the students got a
bit of a taste of the chaos in my hou
and my house at the end of the last
session so
if we have just a couple minutes if
folks have any sort of
either substantive or stylistic
suggestions for josh
thinking forward ahead to his next
presentation if there were parts of the
presentation
um where he lost you or became
uninteresting or problematic or even
parts that like really connected with
you and engaged you i'm sure any of that
feedback
yeah he thinks about that you know and
you're the fact you've seen lots of
these kinds of talks too
so if there are thoughts that you had i
think that would be really really
welcome and valuable
josh who's going to be your audience
sorry
who's gonna be your audience for your
talk um so this is um
it's a at northeastern it's
um the it's their college of art and
media design and also apply
psychology so there will be people who
are more sort of like
media design folks and there are also be
people who are more kind of
like working in schools um
as educational psychologists and so it's
sort of
actually i think this is a good
representation of the diversity so the
people who are like
you know may not know that much about
education but know a lot about design
and people who know a lot about
education but might not know that much
about design um they're also
part of and that's why i spent actually
more time than i would normally is
they're interested in someone to teach
statistical methods and so i want to
also showcase some of my own
ability to explain statistical concepts
um
in in a more late audience um type of
way
from the standpoint of someone like who
was like definitely on the
media and arts and nice things i don't
have numbers
um i gotta say at some point uh you lost
me with the technical stuff
but so i would consider framing it like
as
more more look at the story that you're
telling and not just
start from the methods because um
that might be obstacles yeah that's how
fun
yeah something that was difficult for me
was when you were asking us like to
choose
between seven and ten just because i
couldn't
like see you know like i couldn't yeah
yeah with the other one so yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i thought about that it
might be good to have like the visual
there
um so you can see you can see the the
word distribution
okay yeah
um i guess one one thing and this was
behind i think one of the questions that
i asked
was i was um that the first time when
you were going through the simulation
with the the
video responses from um
from just in it wasn't um
you might want to do a bit more
contextualizing there
in terms of what the user experience is
um yeah yeah and in part
i think it was i was hearing i was
hearing your voice in audio
right um but it wasn't in real time yeah
okay right so then i got confused about
like what
for a person who's actually going
through that simulation
what are they inputting and how yeah and
then how are they experiencing the
response
yeah that's the point yeah i actually
thought about that because it was really
great and people thinking
that i'm talking um in real time
um was it helpful to have that example
like do you think that was helpful
should it be shorter
um
i i appreciated that example yeah
um because in part because of
um you know showing
showing people what the actual
experience is going to look like for
the teachers who are going through the
simulation and that's why
you know kind of fine-tuning that so
that it's
um it's clearer what what that
experience is
um i think would be would make it that
much more effective
yeah okay so that's really helpful yeah
i can definitely
i can definitely do that um
just as a point of clarity i was uh
wanting to make sure i understood
properly that um people can respond
however way they want when they're in
the simulation and those two examples
you gave us the beginning were just
like common examples that represent yeah
yeah
yeah i think that that yeah that's true
so there's sort of like these were two
responses that people gave
and like kind of could give options um
i could have it actually be like
open-ended
um i just wanted to sort of get the
sense of like the the binary
um but i could probably make that clear
that these were like
examples that people gave and then it's
not like in the simulation you have to
choose between these two
um yeah i think so then to the documents
that you're feeding into your model
would be yeah yeah exactly um
but yeah i think i think that i could
make that click that point a little bit
clearer clearer
then now that i understand just to
follow up on that one question i had was
whether um after getting these results
you sort of looked into
some of the responses themselves to see
whether
the kind of i think convergence you were
showing with like a meaningful
convergence or whether
people might be using the same kinds of
words but in different ways
based on yeah maybe it's a good question
um that's actually not something that
we've done um
i've i've thought about it but i haven't
actually kind of like
done a more like i think you would sort
of need to do a kind of qualitative
analysis to actually like look at like
an individual person
um i think that that
like it is very possible
that it is people are picking up like
terminology in the course and then using
it in the simulations which is not like
a bad thing
like it's i think that's actually kind
of what we want it's like people just
sort of like
learn things and then apply it but i
think it i think
and i hope this didn't come off the same
like i'm not saying that now they're
like becoming more equitable and now
they're actually
in the courses here like you know doing
all of the equity practices i think
this is a longer term process i think
what we're showing is that
people within the simulated concepts are
being more cognizant of the type of
issues that someone with already a high
equity
mindset would see in that type of
stimulation
great thank you so much and and
in order to not repeat last
last week's explosion of my daughter
into from the background
um i will um
thank you and and thank everyone who
joined us tonight
and thank you all for your questions and
your feedback
um and um
break a leg well don't literally break a
leg but
if you haven't feedback please feel free
to get in
touch with me my email is
jltvius.mit.edu so any feedback
is very welcome
great thank you bye